new in theaters this weekend
hunter-killer and Johnny English strikes
again what will you see this is your
weekend ticket do you miss the good old
days of 80s and 90s Russian US military
movies as much as I do
well you're in luck Hunter Killer comes
out this weekend it's a cool we're
dealing with a single Road Minister what
if we could free presidents the car we
rescue the Russian president this
submarine military drama starring Gerard
Butler Gary Oldman Linda Cardellini and
common follows the story of a submarine
crew sent to save the Russian president
from a coup
plus there's cool ice explosions fire
this movie is for you if you like
submarine military dramas like Hunt for
Red October or u-571 you're looking for
a solid male role model Gerard Butler of
course or you like a movie with a good
subplot military dramas not your thing
but maybe military spike comedies are
not sure I'm not a man right thank you
let me clear up the uncertainties yeah
you have well check out Johnny English
strikes again also in theaters this
weekend the hilarious Rowan Atkinson
returns as Johnny English in the third
installment of the Johnny English series
English is called out of retirement to
help track down a master hacker who
revealed all of the names of Brittany's
undercover agents this movies for you if
you're a fan of hilarious action
comedies the classic comedic style of
Rowan Atkinson makes you laugh or you're
looking for an excuse to brush off the
old spy tuxedo that's been gathering
dust in your closet that is your weekend
ticket bully you see and check back next
week for some sweet Freddie Mercury me
mustache
[Music]
you